I want to start with talking with Glu
Mobile because what's going on with that
company with your company is really
interesting you've gone from sort of one
hit to many hits no that's right I mean
look we're we're kind of spearheading
what I think is a Hollywood trend which
is that they are trying celebrities are
trying to effectively work directly with
people like ourselves to reach their
fans and cut out I think studios labels
other traditional intermediaries so
Kim's the first of many actually as you
know we we've also seasonally announced
Katy Perry and Katy Perry so your
company you know 225 million in 2020 3
million in sales and a trailing basis
Kim Kardashian is a big part of that the
growth rate in your sales been very
impressive talk to about the kim game we
share an anecdote with you my
nine-year-old was limited to an hour of
screen time every day wanted to play
with my phone one day and she launched
the Kim Kardashian game which I have in
my phone and and she's like dad this
games kind of dumb isn't it and I looked
like 20 minutes later she's still
playing it there's an addictive quality
I guess to that game talking about the
gameplay and how you made that so good a
sentence it's enough I think just to
have a name like Kim Kardashian attached
pioneering experience I mean we worked
on that engine all the way back in
2011-2012 it was a great experience
even without Kim involved with Kim
involved we've really brought to life
this what I call transmedia storytelling
right where Kim's telling this narrative
about what she's doing everyday through
social media print her TV show and
Damian's the next channel that matters
so I think we're really a new media
company that is helping facilitate
transmedia experience people like Kim
people like Blu gamers are finding that
we're part of you know a world that's a
lot bigger than just one individual
phone so you started the development the
game long before Kim was attached to it
we did we did we perfected it actually
before she got involved we knew the game
was going to work what we didn't know
was exactly you know the phenomenon be
it would become but I had a sneaking
suspicion that it could be something
rather special what was how did you you
know get in touch with her how did you
get her involved in the project well we
were looking you know 2012 I thought
long and hard about the future of
Hollywood the future of glue and I
actually went went to Hollywood and did
a couple innovative seminal partnership
deals
we're doing a James Bond movie
game we're doing a terminator game and
Kim was one of these three deals that we
did all of this is impacting now so
Kim's game launched last summer we have
two or three more games that are
exciting with Hollywood this year and
Kim you know I started working with
probably in early 2013 believe it or not
when we started discussing what the
concept could be I went originally
through William Morris which was her
agent right but she got the concept
immediately and I knew we were onto a
good thing because she actually is an
authentic presence with all her social
channels and I knew it could be even
more authentic through a game which in a
lot of ways if you think about it
Kim builds a lot of value for Twitter
and Facebook and so on
you know indirectly her own game is
something that is her brand and so by
spending more time like coming like glue
she's actually building long-term brand
equity for herself now when you're SEC
filings you guys talk about building the
company as a gaming as a service yeah
what does that mean game is a service
that's a great question and we'll talk
more about it I think this morning games
today on phones are not you know single
download short s-curve wonder is like
going to see a movie or going to
download a DVD ultimately we're building
services that look more like annuities
more like a web portal you know Yahoo's
in what its 20th year or something like
that of operating and they had pretty
consistent revenue same thing is
happening with big game franchises so
Glu games as well as our other
competitors in the space have a number
of really large franchises that I think
will go for many many years and I
actually think the Walt wall street's
under estimating how long these
annuities go